I was at the gym in Canada and I did
deadlifts and then I moved on to another
exercise and before and I moved on to
another exercise before I rea rected the
weights and I'm doing the other exercise
I think it was chest and as I'm doing
this other exercise a woman walks over
and goes to start mess with the deadlift
stuff the bar that I didn't reack rack
why why am I saying
reack so I say while I'm working out I
say oh I'm sorry um let me know if you
need help with that I'll I'll do it
after this and she says oh I'm good um
and also let me know if you need help
with
anything at first I was like Wow
Canadians really are nice but now I'm
thinking she said
that because of she wanted to make sure
that she knew that I knew that women
were equal and stuff
and sure
but not
here not at the gym also here's the
other thing I meant to just be like
sorry I didn't re I didn't clean up
after myself but I think she took it as
like hey darling if you need me to lift
anything he heavy I'll do it because you
may not be able to do it because your
tits and [__] might be in the way
like I just being friendly and then she
says let me know if you need help I
should have said oh dude yeah honestly
definitely grab those [__] uh 90b
kettle bells so I can do farmers uh walk
with them I need I need to help with
that pick that up for me you
can't no neither can I but you
can't right I I can I can do I 80 I I'm
I'm comfortable with not 90 but I mean
maybe 90 but 80 I can go a few steps
with so but
dude afterwards I thought about it and I
didn't even want to bring it up to my
own self right like sometimes you're
doing [__] and you're like ah I'm never
going to think about that again it kind
of made me uncomfortable and I didn't
even want to bring it up to my own self
and Denny who I was with working out he
said remember when that happened you
think that girl said that because of
that and said it because of the equality
thing and I was like bro I didn't want
to think that but maybe maybe dude and
so now I'm talking about on the podcast
what do you think I don't know
be equal you know everyone's not equal
you know I mean everyone deserves the
same rights but everyone's not equal
right some people only have like one
arm you're not
equal you deserve the same rights
but people with no arms don't deserve
the same rights I'll say
it
driving you what I'm talking about
operating a
forklift playing B
baseball right
sucks but not everyone's equal and not
even everyone deserves the same rights
wow that now that I think about it
uh-huh
paraplegic
swimming
right you don't do that you can't it's
against the law because it's against the
law to kill yourself and that's
basically what that is I mean you need
floaties I guess but whatever dude I'm
losing people left and right but it's
like
you know not everyone is created equal
remember that whole [__] in the 80s when
they'd be like everyone is created
equal then you'd see your friend with
like [__] one arm then
what sure equal if they're playing you
know the slot machines but